the world was hoping for a lot from the
planet's biggest polluter or at least
something
but china made no new major pledges at
cop26 because that really was the plan
all along just listen to the words of
the man who wasn't there president xi
jinping since i announced the goals of
carbon peak and carbon neutrality last
year
china has formulated an action plan for
carbon dioxide peaking before 2030.
basically china has its own plan and
it's determined to stick to it no matter
the international pressure
that's especially disappointing on coal
the most polluting fossil fuel china
burns more of it than the rest of the
world put together
and it intends to keep increasing its
coal energy capacity until 2025 and only
gradually reduce it after that
it says the economic costs of moving
faster are too great to bear
but we are where we are and if beijing
won't shift its emission targets the
question then becomes how do we make
sure they're sticking to them
and what it shows you here is for the
chosen period of time what is a carbon
emission change for uh ching zhu is a
researcher at xinhua university in
beijing and also at carbon monitor a
project which aims to create a near
real-time dashboard of global emissions
she says that china is taking its
mission seriously now in china i see a
lot more
not just
like national policies but also
responses from local levels like local
governments are really trying to get an
accurate accounting for their carbon try
to figure out where they can cut the
emission
hopefully without damaging economy and
balancing a lot of factors so i really
see local efforts as well
the proof will be in the data the next
decade is crucial for the climate crisis
and up-to-date emissions data will be
important if cop 26 was about words now
it's about the numbers